The other blood work question from somebody else just got my blood work done and my calcium is low.
So, what could cause a low calcium?
So, multiple non-pathological things could cause low calcium.
I breast cancer that have spread to the bone and they want me to increase my calcium to 12,000 to 15,000 milligrams a day and increase vitamin D to 8,000 to 10,000.
I use per day.
What grants do you suggest?
First of all, I would not.
So, if I had metastasis to the bone and low calcium, personally, I would take excess calcium. I would not take 12,000 to 15,000 milligrams a day.
In fact, there's a multiple studies out that shows that when they started recommending 15,000,000 milligrams a day to women back in the seven late 70s and 80s, heart disease went through the roof and women.
It's due to calcification plaque.
You know, the arteries causing stiff arteries and increased blood pressure and cardiovascular disease.
So, taking too much calcium can be dangerous. I think stayed below 1,000 milligrams a day of calcium is is important.
Also, you need to make sure that you're not taking the wrong type of calcium. Most calcium out there is calcium carbonate.
And that is literally limestone.
So, limestone is found in the earth. It's found in the soil. And it's easy to wash and capsulize and sell it is a calcium supplement and calcium carbonate does not absorb in your body.
It's not absorbing. It does not absorb well. And what is absorbed can will laid out in your arteries and will laid out in your ligaments and cause arthritic spurs.
Calcium carbonate is not what you want to take.
The only type of calcium, the only type of minerals that you want to take is our minerals that are key lated the way so calcium carbonate is a key lation.
So, calcium is carbon is calcium is key lated to carbonate C O3 or something I can remember. And that's how it's that's how it's found in nature.
Clients take calcium carbonate and they actually change it to calcium lactate or calcium that's double bonded to a amino acid.
So, either you take a so you want to take a calcium that's key lated as it would be found in nature and in nature, I mean the way we're supposed to eat it so we're supposed to eat plants we're not supposed to eat dirt.
So, we eat plants plants take calcium carbonate they change it to calcium lactate and calcium double bonded by it's called this glycinate so it's typically that should be a double bonded to glyc but it can be double bonded to other amino acids too.
And then you have a mineral that's double bonded to a amino acid that carries it carries it across the gut border very easily and gets it into the cell you need your minerals to get inside the cell to do their work so the cells can use them.
You don't want minerals not able to get inside the cells that just cause that just act like a most like a heavy metal toxicity and that's where if you eat minerals if you take minerals in a elemental form like that you cause damage that's why I'm not a fan of those liquid elemental minerals that's not how we're supposed to take minerals.
And same thing with you see that a lot with iron you'll.
Very similar typically sold in a very poor form so you want to take minerals that are key lated with a double bond to it to be to acid and there's only a couple of companies that make that that way and those are listed as albium minerals.
And tracks I think it's I think it's spelled that way minerals they these companies do not sell directly so these are supplement companies these are paired companies you could say of supplements that then sell to supplement company so supplement.
But if you look at the back of the supplement and it says calcium potassium magnesium and then down below it says a tracks or albium mineral patented by albium and tracks that you know it's a really good supplement because these are double bonded as the same way they be found in nature to an amino acid so your body can use them.
So these are the only minerals that you want to take are the albium and tracks all the companies that we have private labeled use albium and tracks so I personally wouldn't take in the case if this was me and I had low calcium and I am a test this isn't the mode I would only take the clear multiband plus that's our cutters clinic.
And multiband it doesn't have excess amount of calcium it has a good balance and minerals the way you'd find it in nature it's all albium and tracks bound double bonded amino acid minerals so that you'll use it just like your eating really good plants that's the way you want your minerals your vitamin D you can get the vitamin D in the 80 K.
So the 80 K complete is got vitamin D 5000 I use and a and K and that is all your fat soluble vitamins in one of their some benefits to getting all your fat soluble vitamins in one thing.
And if you took two of those a day you'd have plenty of vitamin deep by alkaline phosphatase that's alkaline phosphatase blood work was higher than two weeks ago even after my infusion so your infusion will not typically reduce alkaline phosphatase levels alkaline phosphatase is produced by your liver.
So it can be due to liver congestion but it's also produced if there's a bony, leadic destruction of bone in the case of metastasis to the bone so if the alkaline phosphatase is elevated it's due to the metastasis to the bone it's not and it typically will not be reduced through it's not going to.
So infusion to increase your hemoglobin is not going to help with your alkaline phosphatase levels.
So the other thing I want to speak to this and I'm going to erase this in order to have space for it is if you have metastasis in the bone you really should be on TV go TV go is a brand is US enzymes brand and if I could private label it I would.
US enzymes brand green t extract so the the catacid in green t extract that's so important is the e g c g that's how it's supposed to be written like that that's a catacid and green t extract that is decreases and is one of the only things that has been shown to decrease the.
interleukin six which is an inflammatory cytokine that's found at the surface of the bone.
And especially when there's a litig destruction of the bone so it's at the surface of the bone where there's litig destruction it's an inflammatory cytokine and it is.
You want to decrease the level of IL six at the bone and e g c g will do that I used to say it was the only thing that was discovered they actually did some new research.
and they found that it also acted in the same way curcumid much less e g c g from green t extract and reservoir at all both decrease IL six at the surface of the bone so when there's either.
litig destruction of the bone or even osteoporosis you really the treatment in your first think of oh I have osteoporosis or I have litig destruction of the bone I need to increase my calcium right away and increase the vitamin D will really the first thing it increases you need to increase the things that will decrease the interleukin six at the surface of the bone which is e g c g.
We have several various varicules we only carry good res varicules we have multiple different res varicules on our store so I like the res varicule plus and we private label it from designs for health and it's a great product but that's definitely you want to be out of that.
I'm talking about the TV or the US enzymes is green t extract is the most polluted nutrient across the whole supplement world so all the supplements that exist on planet earth green t extract is the most polluted with pesticides and US enzymes is the most anal company with looking at green t extract.
I like a lot of different supplement companies as US enzymes is the most pure especially for green t extract so that's the only one I really recognize the TV goal and you should really take about three of these a day.
So you need super high dosage and the res varicule plus you will really run about three a day of each one of these but you do have to spread them out because the half life of the res varicules very short green t extract the e g c g is a little bit higher but those varicules very short so you need a spread amounts for the day that will be the best thing to decrease the inflammation at the bone to help you uptake any nutrients that you have.
Certainly what the right calcium you don't need excess calcium you certainly want vitamin D but you need to decrease the inflammation.